Let's consider a
kinematics problem.
And in this problem, we want to
focus on special conditions--
how to think about that.
So what I'm going to consider
is some charged plates,
and I have a charged
particle, and it
enters into this region
of charged plates.
And in this problem,
there's two types
of forces that are going
to act on this particle.
There's a gravitational
force down.
And we're going to talk
about some constant force
upwards, whose magnitude
is changing in time.
And what I'd like to do is
know what type of-- how strong
does this force
have to be-- this b
is a constant-- in order for the
particle to not hit the bottom?
Now, let's think
about a little-- when
we get started on a
problem like this,
there's a number
of different issues
that we have to think about.
The first issue is that how do
we even sketch what we think
will happen here?
Well, a particle enters
at time t equals 0.
So this force is initially
zero when the particle enters.
So the particle is experiencing
gravitational force.
And we should expect
it to move-- start
to accelerate downwards.
But then this force
is increasing in time.
And so at a certain point,
these two forces will balance
and the particle will
have no net force up.
And gradually, this force
will increase so the particle
will experience a force up.
So we would expect
some type of motion
where the particle
starts to go down.
But now, it's starting to
feel that force upwards
and it starts to maybe
move upwards like that.
So what I've done
here is I've sketched
a trajectory of
the motion to help
me think about the problem.